les offices d'achat lem de lyon et de
villeurbanne 13 est aujourd'hui le point
de leurs réalisations
ces réalisations sont impressionnants à
lyon la visite à la du chantier de
pierre valdo ou celui 120 logements au
plateau de la duchère où il sent
l'édifice 13 124 en passant par les
nombreuses et nombreux immeubles qui
sortent de terre dans le quartier des
états unis
actuellement l'office le nain gère douze
mille logements même dynamisme à
villeurbanne où les visiteurs
s'attardèrent surtout sur les chantiers
des bus est actuellement la poussée
démographique est importante un effort
soutenu s'impose et les responsables ont
tous souligné combien les questions de
tarifs et de financement était
préoccupant
de toute façon les offices hlm ont des
projets dans tous les secteurs et il
compte les mener à bien